Сегодня я хотел бы поговорить с вами о
трёх убеждениях, которые мешают
развиваться любому человеку. И первое
убеждение, которое мешает нам
развиваться - это убеждение, которое в
своё время описали психологи Данинг и
Крюгер. Этот эффект, он так и называется
эффект Данинга Крюгера. В чём его суть?
Суть заключается в том, что чем менее
человек компетентен, а, тем больше он
уверен. Чем более компетентен, тем
больше в нём сомнений и отсутствие
уверенности. Человек проходит через
определённые стадии. Первая стадия
называется неосознанная
некомпетентность, когда человек даже не
осознаёт, что он некомпетентен, но при
этом он железобетонно уверен, потому что
у него нет сомнений, он что-то в голову
себе вбил одно, и он в этом сильно
уверен. На этой стадии а обычно
присутствует э самоуверенность. Люди
делают самоуверенные какие-то поступки,
а потом это приводит к ошибкам. Вторая
стадия - это ложная компетентность.
Ложная компетентность, когда человек
считает себя компетентным. Третья стадия
- это
осознанная некомпетентность, когда
человек осознаёт, что он некомпетентен.
И вот с этого момента человек начинает э
развиваться дальше и осознавать свою
компетентность и либо некомпетентность.
С этого момента начинается настоящее
развитие человека. Например, в авиации я
в своё время, когда начал заниматься
авиацией, я для себя посмотрел
статистику а несчастных случаев в
авиации. И знаете, интересный график я
увидел. Первое, оказывается, наибольшее
количество аварий происходит в начальной
стадии, когда человек ээ набирает себе
до 100 часов налётов. Дальше со 100
часов до примерно 1.200 часов налётов
аварийны только падает. Статистика
показывает, что аварийны столько падает.
начиная где-то с 1.200 часов налётов,
аварийность опять резко возрастает и
выходит на второй пик. И где-то начиная
с 1.7001800 часов налётов аварийность
падает, падает, падает, и где-то в
районе 5-6.000
часов налётов аварийнис опять делает
небольшой пик, а дальше только идёт на
снижение до 10.000 часов налёта. А о чём
это говорит? Смотрите, первое, когда
приходят новички, только научились
летать на самолёте, у них появляется
неосознанная
некомпетентность. Смотрите, первое в
начале они всего боятся. И вот здесь они
совершают аварии, потому что они не
понимают, они некомпетентные, они не
знают. Дальше в какой-то момент, когда
они более-менее научились летать,
начинают летать от 100 часов до 1.200
часов, они летают, их компетенция
возрастает, возрастает, и в какой-то
момент они начинают чувствовать себя,
что они уже всё знают. Они думают, что
всё знают, и у них появляется ложная э
компетентность. Они думают, что они всё
увидели уже. И вот на 1.200 часов дальше
опять возрастает аварийность, появляется
второй пик. После этого человек
осознаёт, что он некомпетентен, начинает
развиваться, аварийность начинает
падать, падать, падать. И вот
в районе 5-6.000 налётов у человека
появляются определённые шоры. Он уже
опытный, у него возникает ощущение, что
он всё видел, всё знает, а и он начинает
пренебрегать, а техникой безопасности.
Он начинает пренебрегать какими-то
процедурами, которые влияют напрямую на
безопасность. И интересно, вот этот
эффект Данига Крудигера - это не
разделение людей на глупых и умных. Это,
на самом деле, проходит каждый человек,
когда начинает заниматься каким-то
делом. Например, если вы на хотите
заняться фотографией, вы пройдёте
однозначно через все эти стадии. Первая
стадия - это неосознанная
некомпетентность. Вторая стадия - это
ложная компетентность, когда вы
научитесь делать первые снимки и будете
думать: "Ой, как легко, оказывается,
ничего в этом сложного нет". И дальше
третья стадия, когда вы поймёте, что это
гораздо сложнее, чем вам казалось, до
этого у вас появляется третья стадия -
это осознанная некомпетентность. И вот
начиная с осознанной некомпетентности,
дальше вы уже становитесь напрямую
дорожку саморазвития и
самосовершенствования.
Следующее убеждение, которое мешает нам
развиваться, я заметил, что люди к 40-50
годам, ну, поразному бывает, но в
среднем, если брать, начинают думать,
что они уже в жизни практически всё
видели. Они всё видели, всё знают, везде
бывали, они опытные, бывалые и так
далее. И самое интересное, чем больше
человек видел там событий, находился в
гуще событий, на чем более у него бурная
насыщенная жизнь, тем больше он попадает
в эту иллюзию, что он уже в жизни всё
знает, всё видел. И вот этот опыт,
который наслоённый годами на человека,
он как бы создаёт иллюзию, что этот мир
предсказуем,
что, в принципе, везде работают одни и
те же паттерны, и что уже особо нет
смысла изучать что-то новое. Всё это так
или иначе повторяется. И вот этот опыт
является очень э таким большим грузом. А
о чём этот опыт говорит? Опыт говорит о
том, что так как я видел уже много
всего, то что бы ни произошло, то это
будет повторять то, что было в прошлом.
Но будущее всегда непредсказуемое.
Будущее всегда к нам приходит не тогда,
когда мы ожидаем, не так, как мы
ожидаем, не в той форме, которую мы
ожидаем. И поэтому к будущему
приготовиться на 100% практически
невозможно. Поэтому, а, иметь опыт -
это, конечно, хорошо. А, но я бы
рекомендовал к опыту относиться к своему
как к определённому справочнику. То есть
вы изучаете какую-то тему, а потом
посматриваете на опыт, коррелируют это с
вашим опытом или нет. Поэтому второе
убеждение, которое нам сильно мешает
развиваться - это убеждение, что мы всё
знаем, что мы всё видели и мы всё умеем.
Поэтому я бы рекомендовал осторожнее
относиться к своему опыту и не
переоценивать его его. И третье
убеждение. Или, я даже сказал бы не
убеждение, а не это целый комплекс
убеждений. Это неправильная логика.
Зачастую наша бытовая логика не
соответствует правильной логике. О чём я
хотел бы поговорить. Вот существует
определённая хронологическая
последовательность событий, а и
существует причинноследственная
последовательность событий. Так вот,
очень часто люди путают хронологическую
и причиноследственную
последовательность. Если какое-то
событие произошло после чего-то, то
очень часто люди думают, что это
произошло из-за этого. И здесь хотелось
бы чётко разъяснить, что если событие
произошло после чего-то, это не значит,
что из-за этого. И вот это очень важно,
особенно касательно в бизнесе и в
отношениях между людьми. Вы знаете, вот
в казиной технологии есть такое правило,
аа, когда вы должны чётко пройти по
причины следственной связи. Вот приведу
такой пример, чтобы легче было понимать.
Вот, предположим, подул ветер и листья
посыпались дерева. Наша бытовая логика
подразумевает, что листья посыпались,
потому что подул ветер. На самом деле
листья посыпались, потому что наступила
осень. И вот здесь есть второй слой,
который очень важно различать. это, э,
поверхностные причины и корневые
причины. Так вот, чтобы легче
разбираться или не путаться в
причинно-следственной связи и находить
корневые причины, а обычно при решении
проблем, пока вы не решите корневую
причину этой проблемы, проблема не
решится. Для этого в казинг технологии
есть
такой инструмент, называется пять
почему. Когда происходит какое-то
событие, задавайте вопрос пять почему?
Вот давайте на этом примере с листьями я
приведу. Первое, листья посыпались.
Почему? Потому что подул ветер. А
почему, э, подул ветер или почему листья
посыпались? Вот там две ветки может
быть. Ветер подул, потому что погода
портится, а листья посыпались, потому
что осень наступила. А почему листья
осыпаются, когда наступает осень? Потому
что становится холодно, там сок деревьев
не идёт, листья отмирают. И почему сок
не идёт там и листья отмирает? Потому
что становится холодно. А почему
становится холодно? Потому что сменился
сезон. Ну я не буду говорить дальше уже
про то, что солнце, Земля от солнца начи
уходит на дальнюю часть своей орбиты и
так далее. Ну, ну суть такая. Мы
понимаем, что корневая причина - это
смена сезона. И если задавать пять
вопросов почему, то вы всегда придёте к
корневой причине, которую, кстати, э
решить гораздо легче и дешевле. Вот по
ходу я вам дам один хороший лайфхак.
Каждый раз, когда вы сталкиваетесь с
любой проблемой, вы знаете, это уже
доказано, что решение корневой причины
гораздо дешевле, легче и быстрее, чем
решать последствия. Поэтому, м, когда
вашему саморазвитию мешает неправильная
логика, чтобы её убрать, её устранить,
всегда возьмите себя за правила или за
привычку докапываться до корневых
причин. И вот это вот этот инструмент
почему не даст вам возможности сбиться с
пути именно с этой причиноследственной
цепочки.